first there was the fouchi pandemic then
supply chain then we get inflation then
we get interest rates and the real
estate market goes crazy oh my gosh it's
something all the time and then you get
Christmas ah Hey listen you ever feel
stuck me too a lot of us have felt stuck
at one time or another we want to help
you break the cycle we know how to get
unstuck and we know how how to help you
get unstuck with your money as well
January the 11th we're going to do a
live stream it's completely free you
don't want to miss it it's going to be
Rachel Cruz me George camel Dr John
deloney and Jade warshaw we're going to
help you break the cycle January 11th
don't miss it